so i'm going to tell you a little story
about how you can use all the leftover
bits to make food and watch me
meat and bone now who would still eat
this
[Music]
jamie oliver has an interesting
relationship with chicken nuggets and
it's something i find deeply fascinating
because it's this weird convergence of
both an extremely political rhetoric and
one man's personal pride it's a conflict
that has led the man to take on chicken
nuggets in some form in every show he's
made to flex over them and display
superiority right down to basically
lying like in the 2011 miniseries
jaime's dream school where he promises a
room full of troubled teens that he can
teach them to make nuggets better
cheaper and faster than frozen nuggets
and this is one pound 90. it's 10 pence
cheaper i'm gonna do it in half the
amount of time and this is do you think
this is better for you or that
all the way back in 2005 on the show
jamie's school dinners jamie
demonstrated the contents and production
of chicken nuggets for a group of
children which is as with a lot of food
kind of gross
these are the kids that won't eat my
chicken you know these are the kids that
want their their nuggets back so i want
to show them what's in their [ __ ]
nuggets then what they do
is they add more chicken skin
that
is how that part is made at the end he
asks if any of the kids still want
nuggets and all of them decline
anyone one of these
in 2010 on the show jamie oliver's food
revolution the production recreated the
scenario with kids from huntington west
virginia but this time when jamie asks
if they still want the nuggets after
learning how they're made
all the kids say yes now who would still
eat this
[Music]
they all want those nugs and who can
blame them chicken nuggets are delicious
this bit is one of those clips that's in
a sort of perpetual virality every few
months it makes the rounds again with a
new caption new commentary and new
conclusion for the audience to draw and
it's one that fascinates me because
jaime's argument against chicken nuggets
is just
so comically bad there's a lot of
possible arguments against chicken
nuggets a lot of reasons you can
consider chicken nuggets to be bad and
jaime is making
none of them for example you can argue
that chicken nuggets are a product of a
corrupt industry that is often deeply
inhumane towards the animals that pass
through it making it immoral to enjoy
the products of that inhumanity or you
can argue that eating meat is
intrinsically immoral that we have for
the most part move past the need to get
sustenance at the expense of animals you
can argue that the meat industry is
exploitative of its workers at the
mundane and merely engaging in
aggressive anti-union practices and
predatory hiring of migrant workers who
can then be threatened with punitive use
of the immigration system and at the
extreme end
buying slaves from christian drug rehab
programs but jamie's argument against
chicken nuggets is that they're bad
because they're made from the bad parts
of the bird arguing that there are the
good clean parts of the chicken that are
appropriate to eat and the rest of the
bird which is garbage take this bit for
example which uses the grammar of
television to suggest that even the kids
see this plainly obvious fact now
chicken wings are worth quite a lot of
money i showed them where all the nice
cuts of meat came off the chicken so we
just popped the legs off and then you're
left with a carcass with all the ribs
and the little bits of giblets and blood
and skin and stuff like that what do you
think happens to this
it gets thrown away
he'll have people sniff store-bought
chicken nuggets and ask weird leading
questions like doesn't this smell dirty
but then no one ever responds because it
probably just smells like a chicken
nugget now smell your nugget and then
smell the other one
your one should sort of smell quite
clean
and then the other one smells a bit
dirty jamie makes a lot of hay about
mechanically reclaimed meat and indeed
the entire thrust of his scare
presentation with these kids revolves
around the fact that the middle parts of
the process where they take the bad
dirty parts of the bird and process it
into food are kind of gross looking the
process involves taking the parts of the
carcass that aren't prime cuts of meat
parts that still have a lot of good
muscle tissue attached a lot of
connective tissue and gristle which
aren't very tasty but contain collagen
and elastin which breaks down into
useful amino acids leftover skin removed
from cuts that are sold skinless organs
and bone marrow grinding that into a
paste straining out larger solids than
using the resulting meat goo as an
ingredient in food like chicken nuggets
and you know what i will concede this
fact the stuff looks gross
i would not pipe tepid meat goo into my
mouth this does not make me hungry but
so what
lots of food looks gross when it's raw
or partially cooked we literally have a
popular phrase about the making of
sausage for this exact reason if your
requirement is that food look delicious
and appealing at all stages of
preparation then i'm sorry that's really
a you problem so like i said there's a
lot of reasons to criticize the food
industry the meat industry above all but
what you can't really argue about the
meat industry and chicken nuggets in
specific is that they're wasteful and
this is something of a complexity of the
issue
they definitely use all of the bird now
make no mistake this frugality is in no
way motivated by an ideological aversion
to waste but rather stems from
maximizing the return on their product
literally anything left over at the end
of the process they're going to try to
find someone to sell it to mineral
solids contain keratin and calcium so
dry it out grind it up and mix it with
fertilizer organ proteins are used in
pet food various soft proteins fats hair
hide feathers and other by-products can
be rendered into glycerin gelatin oils
lubricants and pastes which are used in
food cosmetics pharmaceuticals and
industrial applications it is
notoriously difficult to go truly 100
vegan because products often contain
other products that are themselves made
in part with animal products which
is complicated because if you're going
to accept that it's okay to eat animals
and use animal products which at the
moment is the mainstream opinion in our
society then
clearly if you're going to use the bird
at all
you should use the whole bird now while
pink goo isn't the apocalyptic nutrient
void that jamie oliver wants to paint it
as it is undeniably the lower quality
stuff i don't want to mislead you into
thinking that frozen nuggets are
something that they aren't they're not
great but
you already knew that but like
it's not sawdust it's still food after
taking the prime cuts off a bird there's
a lot of second rate but usable
nutrients left on and in the bones this
is why it was customary in ye olden days
that after you ate all the easy parts
off a roast chicken you'd boil the
scraps and bones to pull out whatever
was left and create chicken stock at
least that's what you do
if you're too poor to just buy another
chicken if you can't afford to not
extract
every last calorie out of the bird you
bought now i don't want to suggest that
jamie oliver is classist i don't know
the secrets that lay in the inner
cloisters of his heart but
these arguments definitely are oliver
isn't arguing against nuggets because of
what they contain or because they tie
into complicated questions of morality
and the ethics of eating meat or even
entirely because of their actual
nutritional value more on that later but
because of what they represent which is
a low-class diet this is the language
being evoked the implication that
low-class people are dirty and thus
cheap and dirty are synonymous
there's bits on it that are worth lots
of money the breasts are the most
expensive part it's the biggest and it's
the white meat okay the other thing that
i want to talk about briefly is the
rhetorical function of this clip
something fascinating about it is that
from the point of view of the production
from the messaging viewpoint there
really isn't a wrong answer to jaime's
offer of nuggets meaning that no matter
what answer the kids give i
as the conceptual author of the show
can use it
i can use the whole bird if the kids
reject the processed nuggets they
validate the assertion that nuggets
aren't just low quality cheap food made
from leftovers but are dirty and
inedible if the kids still want the
nuggets even knowing that before being
cooked they were a pink slime then that
validates jaime's superiority the
assertion that america is doomed that
the kids are broken that there is a
spiritual epidemic and that is exactly
how it's employed in the actual episode
i mean what's scary is that we've
brainwashed our kids so brilliantly
so even though they know something is
disgusting and gross they'll still eat
it if it's in that friendly little shape
as a fascinating extension the clip as
it makes its rounds through memetic
cycles alternates how it's being
employed based on what community it's
passing through it is shared in equal
measure by people laughing at jamie
oliver getting dunked on by some kids
who want them saucy nugs and people who
agree with jaime that this reflects a
metaphysical illness in society which is
the source of the physical illness of
obesity now this argument is stupid but
it's also extremely popular there is a
pervasive belief in our society that
poorness is a moral failing that the
poor inflict on themselves that the
disastrous and growing class divides in
the world are the result of a type of
person who just loves chicken nuggets so
much that they're not willing to stop
being poor of course that's all
extremely wrong the real answers are far
more complex school lunches suck because
there's no money for quality ingredients
the staff are often poorly trained if
not unqualified because there's no money
for training or hiring qualified
personnel there's no money for hiring
qualified personnel because of a belief
that school lunch lady is a meaningless
trivial job where you slop food at
children and not a position where you're
expected to serve food to several
hundred people in a mere 45 minutes the
logistics don't magically get easier
just because the patrons aren't old
enough to buy cigarettes there's no
money for quality food because there's
no political will to allocate that money
and there's no political will because of
all sorts of messed up priorities
including the belief that pornis is a
self-inflicted problem why that sounds
like a vicious cycle doesn't it you
could address this complexity and in
fairness jamie oliver hasn't strictly
ignored this even as he's drafted lunch
menus that would drain an entire year's
budget in a month but it's a lot easier
to look at chicken nuggets as a thing
that just happens to be in proximity to
the problem and blame it for everything
back to jaime's dream school oliver
promises that he can make nuggets
cheaper faster and better than the
store-bought nuggets and it ends up
exposing a lot of the charade and this
is one pound 90. it's 10 pence cheaper
i'm gonna do it in half the amount of
time and this is do you think this is
better for you or that now to a degree
he's not strictly lying if you have a
very well laid out kitchen all the
ingredients a familiarity with the
recipe and confidence in your tools and
technique then measuring from the moment
you start to when you start eating
you can
probably make fried chicken strips
faster than an oven can heat up a box of
tenders and the recipe he gives here i
mean
it's lightly seasoned fried chicken
probably tastier than most nuggets as
long as you make it right and you know
what it might even cost you less by
weight than the most expensive box of
chicken in the grocery more than twice
as much as the cheap box though just for
the chicken breast not including the
other ingredients also this isn't really
that much healthier it's still got
plenty of salt it's still fried in oil
but also
healthy versus unhealthy is really a
terrible way of conceptualizing food in
the first place this is actually a
persistent problem with oliver's version
of healthy eating which really isn't
driven by actual nutritional value he
still uses a lot of sugar and salt but
is better conceptualized again as clean
versus dirty things with lots of listed
ingredients are bad things with fewer
ingredients are good regardless of what
those are
don't
24 25 26 27 28 29 30.
31 32 30 30 44 35 46
40 41 42 40
44 okay
how many ingredients in there guys so
he's not lying but the whole exercise
requires so many caveats and so much
deck stacking that it is disingenuous
it's just an extension of the argument
that poorness is the result of things
like food choices rather than food
choices being largely dictated by being
poor i mean one you're probably not
buying the 16 box you're buying the
seven dollar box and you're not coming
home and heating up two dollars worth of
mechanically reclaimed chicken strips
because everything else in your life is
going great the biggest hole in all of
it of course is the issue of time with
the stacked deck the linear time is
about comparable but what's not
comparable at all is the actual amount
of work i mean it it's so self-evident
that i i feel insane even pointing it
out jaime's fried chicken bites are good
but you spend the entire time
making fried chicken plus it generates a
huge amount of mass that you will then
need to clean up food prep is extremely
time and energy intensive and it's
maddening that so much of the hay about
healthy eating relies on pretending that
it's not
so the whole thing is an argument that
displays such a fundamental lack of
understanding about why people eat what
they do and it's a dangerous argument
because again
it's a popular argument and it's popular
with the kind of people who write and
pass laws seemingly every day there's
another proposal for a law to heavily
tax unhealthy food or arbitrarily remove
things like soda french fries and
chicken nuggets from the already asinine
list of things food assistance can and
can't be spent on food is an almost
unfathomably complex subject and there
are very real issues of public health
and ecology tied up in it people broadly
eat what they have access to and access
is dictated by class and class in our
society is so very often dictated by
race it's about free time stress how far
away you live from a grocery store
whether or not you live in a
neighborhood where the freshest
vegetable is the lettuce in a big mac it
connects to problems with jobs wages the
physical design of our cities the
priorities of our politicians and the
incentives of our economic system it's a
big intensely complex problem which is
why it's ultimately a lot easier to just
be a stooge to go on tv and blame the
audience for having bad taste like no
you're making the nuggets wrong you're
making dirty nuggets
stop making dirty nuggets
[Music]
almost every night
chew and suck my chicken treats into the
calm swallow please